bonjour jean baptiste eyraud merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
à la base il y avait plus de 1200 sans
abri inquiété au parc andré citroën
certains ont été hébergés en
ile-de-france 546 170 autres ont été
transférés à rennes compiègne ou
ailleurs sans le savoir en france selon
un sans papiers de témoin cité dans
libération alors qu'il demandait aux
chauffeurs ou est-ce qu'ils allaient ce
dernier a répondu rester tranquille on
n'a pas le droit de vous le dire qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette scène est ce
qu'elle est elle réelle établi et les
passagers auraient tué aurait-il dû être
prévenu qu est ce que ça traduit en gros
à écouter les témoignages convergent
dans ce sens ça c'est à dire que
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu on va
dire la région parisienne quand ils ont
vu les bus passent et les péages ils ont
commencé à s'interroger s'inquiéter
cette année ils ont compris qu'ils
allaient sans doute tout cas beaucoup
plus loin que que la région parisienne
et donc certains noms commencent à
s'enquérir auprès du chauffeur donc il
ya ya quelques chauffeurs qui ont dit
pendant la pause à la pause aurait coûté
là je vais à tel endroit ce qui vaut ne
pas descendre du car il ya des cars
aussi où il y avait des militaires et
des policiers
donc où il on parle plus vraiment
descendre des cartes ça dépend des
lauriers débuts sur nous a raconté il ya
un bus qui est arrivé à besançon puis
qui est arrivé
comment dirais-je à dijon ensuite qui a
été à besançon les policiers sont montés
dans le car et des ans ils les ont
suivis ensuite enfin ils les ont
contrôlés en quelque sorte pour empêcher
que ceux qui ne voulaient pas rester
dans le cadre de saint mary's avertir
les sans abri de leur destination finale
qu'est ce que ça traduit pas écouter ça
traduit un piège simplement c'est un
guet-apens c'est à dire que on a mis ces
personnes sans abri par parmi lesquels
il ya un certain nombre de sans papiers
on les a on les a on ne les a pas
informés on leur a tendu un piège et
quand ils sont arrivés ils sont sortis
but cela puisse les attendait donc il ya
eu des contres et parmi lesquels
effectivement
on voit à peu près une cinquantaine de
personnes qui étaient qui ont été mignan
en centre de rétention administrative
plusieurs dizaines de personnes qui ont
été piégés en fait pas recette
par cette seconde étape en administratif
et en place par l'institution met en
place par l'état nous on est scandalisé
on est choqué parce que tout le monde y
compris les associations du collectif
réquisition avait confiance nous avions
confiance et les sans abri aussi avec
confiance ce que c'est la dixième à la
onzième opération plume oignons donc
pour faire en sorte que les personnes
sans abri soit hébergée est à toi quelle
que soit leur situation administrative
donc vous êtes faut signaler aussi que
même si elles sont pas à paris en région
parisienne elles ont un toit mais
ailleurs oui mais si vous voulez
parmi ces sans abri on a ça tangue qui
sont donnés ci de nationalité française
qui ont un emploi ou qui en titre de
séjour et qui travaille qui ont leurs
enfants qui sont scolarisés dans des
écoles en haut lieu de vie habituel
enfin je veux dire on déplace pas de
cette manière là sans prévenir les gens
les déplacer c'est un déplacement forcé
en fête qui leur a été imposée avec à
l'arrivée et bien est ce que voulait
rester là est ce que voulait pas rester
là où toute façon les autorités n'ont
pas été surpris je me fais l'avocat du
diable à ce que les autorités n'ont pas
été surprise de cette occupation
soudaine est il légal du parc andré
citroën elles ont peut-être agi dans la
précipitation
illégale non réponse il avait été inégal
s'il avait été jugé illégal par la ville
de paris il aurait demandé l'expulsion
elle n'a pas fait elle la ville de paris
a jugé que c'était cette installation
temporaire très provisoire était
légitime par contre ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'état ne s'est pas donné les
moyens effectivement de d'accueillir de
mettre en place des structures des
solutions d'hébergement pour les 1200
personnes qui étaient là et donc a mis
en place j'irai dans une logique
purement répressive 1 pour décourager
aussi les sans abri de 2
d'autres sans abri de devenir dans ce
type d'initiative
parmi eux pardonnez moi parce qu'il
reste plus beaucoup de temps je me
permets de vous couper pour aller très
vite on sait qu'il ya un contexte
migratoire actuelle assez particulier
puisqu'il ya des migrants afghans qui
viennent s'ajouter à cela qu'est ce que
vous proposez pour éviter une crise
migratoire similaire à celle vécue en
2015 par l'union européenne écoutez il
faut simplement que la france qui est un
pays riche encore et qui dispose de
trois millions de logements vacants qui
a beaucoup de locaux publics qui sont
désaffectés met en place les moyens d
accueillir convenablement mais si vous
voulez pour nous ce qu'on demande
globale non c'est l'application de la
loi qui prévoit le droit à l'hébergement
pour toute personne sans abri en
situation de détresse et de telle sorte
à ce que n'est plus personne dans les
rues fins et le président mâcon s'est
engagé sa promesse manifestement n'est
pas tenue on a toujours beaucoup de sans
abri dans les rues quel que soit leur
nationalité
y compris des sans abri français insulté
français et enfin si cette dramatique
l'instit la crise du logement que nous
vivons aujourd'hui est que la
conséquence directe des politiques du
logement merci jean baptiste eyraud
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
de l'association droit au logement c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi